if you're in the plains of Africa and
you
think you see a lion in the bushes and
then you run away and you run you live
to see another day there if you
investigate
well no this that's what kills curiosity
that's why people aren't curious because
I wonder if that's a lion let me go find
out
[Music]
star talks sports edition I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist and I'm joined by my two
co-hosts Gary O'Reilly Gary I knew all
right and of course Chuck Knight Chucky
baby hey hey what's happening Neil So
today we're going to talk about
skepticism something so deep to my heart
in everything in this world and when are
you appropriately skeptic and when are
you just wrong and doubting everything
and therefore believing nothing when
there's stuff out there where there's
sufficient evidence to support it these
are Big questions that apply to so many
walks of life and it especially applies
to the Health and Fitness and Nutrition
industry oh it was time we went there
and so Gary did some homework on this so
Gary tell me what you put together for
today uh well we're going to start off
we're going to engage the critical
thinking and the skeptical mind uh and
then drop some numbers on you quickly
the health and fitness industry is
valued at around
four trillion dollars oh oh that's
that's nothing 90 billion dollars a year
is spent on health club membership so if
you're like a spa day so that we can
drive by the place and go I belong there
that's it nobody I should have gone this
morning and I did nobody sees the inside
of their gym they just point at it on
the way by to someplace else now add in
a hundred billion dollars a year on
dietary supplements now ask yourself
how many of those products are
underpinned by a strong peer-reviewed
evidence then ask yourself
oh how many how many of them are made of
sawdust is that the next question it's
me you know we'll get there we'll get
there ask yourself are our critical
faculties still analog while we operate
in a digital world with fake news bad
science and really crappy social media
and then ask yourself are you just
describe Twitter bro oh did I sorry
um and then ask yourself why do we
default to Quick Fix Solutions not just
in workouts exercise but diets and other
things so for all of this we need an
expert Dr Nick tiller senior research
fellow in exercise physiology at Harbor
UCLA Medical Center a leading Authority
on physiology and pathophysiology of
extreme exercise an elite level marathon
runner an ultra marathon runner and an
Iron Man competitor he's also the author
of The Skeptics Guide to sports science
considered to be and not by me but by
people who know these things one of the
best sports science books of all time
I'm skeptical of that statement you
should be me too
welcome Nick tiller to StarTalk dude
it's great to be here thanks for having
me guys excellent excellent we need you
the world needs you and let's see if we
can milk from you as much as we possibly
can for our audience because this is
very important uh content and so so let
me just start off by asking what what
were some of your like how did you land
in this field
so I I come from a sports science
background in the US it's much more
broadly Kinesiology in in UK and Europe
export and exercise science it might my
first two degrees my my undergraduate
and my masters in exercise physiology
Sports Nutrition and at the time like
most other people in my position I
desperately wanted to work in high
performance sport if you do a poll among
all undergraduate students you know 95
of them put their hands up they all want
to work in sport and after I graduated
with my masters this was back in about
2006 2007 and I started to work with
athletes and coaches and become more
involved in the health and fitness
industry
it became immediately obvious to me that
all of the values that we hold so dear
in terms of
the scientific process the scientific
methods scientific skepticism you know
being humble showing humility
evidence-based practice uh prioritizing
the process of inquiry above the
conclusions mitigating of bias there's a
there's a these are in stark contrast to
what we see in health and fitness where
marketing is King and where the science
really is subordinate to the marketing
so you described it you describe
principles of Engagement that should
apply to all branches of human inquiry
right right and so and now you're saying
there's a gap there in in your field
that that's that's that's too bad you
can't sell snake oil
with the scientific method
exactly but they're rationalizing that
out
if you're going to pull the roll over
people's eyes you can't do real science
and that's the point isn't it is that
the the health and wellness we just said
it's worth over four trillion dollars
you don't get this kind of valuation by
you know following mainstream science
and by tempering your conclusions uh
it's all about sensationalism and uh
trying to get the biggest bang for your
buck so I've been trying to bring these
two worlds of critical thinking and uh
and their health and fitness
a little bit closer together so before
we get I don't want to get I have a
tendency to get ahead of the show but I
don't want to so I'm going to ask this
in the most General way possible
of uh the amount of products on the
market knowing that many of them are
bogus
is it that some of them have a very
small benefit that is exaggerated
or is it that the mo the majority of
them are just straight up bunk but by
the way you can be bunk and still
believe it works and then have it work
that's the placebo right oh what a great
great yeah that's right the placebo
right right so so can you disentangle
that for us you're describing I guess
the difference between misinformation
and disinformation you know somebody who
who inadvertently propagate some
erroneous advice against somebody who
deliberately propagates uh erroneous
advice in order to you know line their
pockets
yeah exactly so to ask you a question
there's a broad spectrum so at one end
of the spectrum you have products that
are just completely bogus so for example
Chiropractic for in terms of the
disparity between the claims made for
Chiropractic and the evidence and
support of those claims the disparity is
as huge there as I've ever seen for any
intervention so this thing is not based
on any scientific evidence at all I'm
probably going to get emails now but you
know whatever I was about to say please
send oh your corresponds
I point my nose in the direction of the
Sciences we all do right but but then it
the other is kind of end of the spectrum
you have products where the plausible
claims are intertwined with the
implausible so for example I'm doing a
talk this weekend about pseudoscience in
distance running at the London Marathon
conference and one of the products that
are often that are often sold to Runners
are massage guns you know these these
things you can hold and you push them
into the muscle and it helps to release
muscle pain and this kind of thing and
on the one hand they say that it can
reduce muscle soreness and reduce scar
tissue and help with you know pain in
the muscle and this kind of thing but
these same vendors say that it can cure
diabetes that it can that it can reduce
inflammation that it the the claim that
I love the best is that it can it can
help with high blood pressure and low
blood pressure
right so you've got to pick one so um
and you know things like Yoga Yoga is
really effective and it's a brilliant
exercise to do for all sorts of
different things
um but the the plausible claims are
often intertwined with implausible
claims like you know healing and
improving energy flow and this kind of
thing which don't conform to what we
know about how the world works so
there's there's a broad spectrum of
things tell me about the placebo then so
so let let it let it be sugar pills but
I think it works and then in some cases
it works so how does where does the
placebo land in your Skeptics portfolio
and this is a huge gray area because I
get asked this a lot it comes down to
the essence of what's the harm right and
particularly in high performance sport
if an athlete tries an intervention that
we know only works in the context of
placebo so that's expectation and belief
then Placebo has a very powerful
psychobiological effects if an athlete
believes that they're feeling a little
bit you know less pain or that their
inflammation has been reduced that they
can run a bit faster jump a little bit
higher this is this is very important
for the athlete especially when you
consider marginal gains where every one
percent every 0.1 percent counts the
difference between gold and silver is
you know infinitesimally small so so
every kind of advantage that the athlete
can get is worthwhile
the problem that we have is that it's
impossible to restrict Placebo products
to Just Sports Performance and Health
and Fitness and Wellness if somebody
really believes in the pain relieving or
the healing properties of this Placebo
it's only going to be a matter of time
before they try and use it to treat
something that requires an actual
medical intervention you know if you
have a bacterial infection there's a
good chance you're going to need
antibiotics you're treating it with some
kind of naturopathic remedy isn't going
to do and that the scientific literature
and then we end in the media as well are
littered with very tragic examples of
people trying to treat real medical
ailments with Placebo medicine and so
that's when it bleeds into mainstream
practice clinical practice and it can
happen so what you're saying is the
placebo whatever power of mind you have
over body that there's a limit where the
placebo effect just goes away if I break
a bone I can't take a placebo and have
the bone repair itself for example right
right so clearly there's a crossover
point from one to the other sometimes uh
just left to your own devices in certain
cases your body will heal itself I have
a friend who had covid went into the
hospital and demanded hydroxychloroquine
I'm not sure if they gave them that or
not I'm not sure if they gave them that
or not but he is under the impression
that they did and he got better but he
was going to get better
period wait did he go to a horse doctor
or did he go
shortly after so doctor
in that in the intro I said that our
critical faculties are kind of set on
analog while we exist in this 21st
century digital age why why are our
critical faculties kind of ill-equipped
to handle this modern marketing what
what is going on that we just can't flip
a switch and see The Emperor's New
Clothes aren't really there
right and and it really comes down to
when you think about the way that human
logic and reason has evolved over time
to to make decisions in terms of the
decision-making process so we evolved
logic and reason for navigating
hypersocial groups for predicting
patterns in the environment you know so
whether it's predicting the weather
patterns or the migration migrating
patterns of animals because these things
served us an evolutionary survival
Advantage so evolutionary pressure has
made sure that these traits have been
passed on
and uh but human genes in human lives
are now incongruent when you look at the
dramatic change in our environment just
in the last 50 years since the Advent of
the internet particularly social media
we have not evolved logic and reason and
critical faculties to deal with
bad science commercialism social media
fake news and all of these things
um and and rampant capitalism and
commercialism which is really uh the
whole point of this is to exploit our
pre-existing biases right to get us to
to make purchases that we don't
necessarily need we can track herds but
there aren't any herds left too to drive
exactly exactly so so we've evolved
these skills which once served a
survival Advantage but the world has
changed a lot but and our genes haven't
changed dramatically and you could you
could say that our that our our ability
to you know update our our underlying
genetics is kind of lacking lagging
behind the the rapidity the speed with
which the environment is changing so I'm
going to say that we've never been good
at it to be honest I'm just going to go
a step further that our brains although
uh Adept at recognizing patterns have
never been good at really recognizing
the true underpinnings or underlying
reasons for those patterns what we've
been able to do is identify them and
that and science actually gets to the
reason behind things and that's where
the disconnect is no no Chuck the
problem is in the simplest case I know
of and Nick can back me up on this if I
get it right that if you are in the if
you're in the plains of Africa and you
think you see a lion in the bushes right
and then you run away and you run you
live to see another day there if you
investigate if you're right well no this
that's what kills curiosity that's why
people aren't curious because I wonder
if that's a lion let me go find out
right okay but no but that that's why
there were no white people in Africa we
had to wait until we came out of Africa
suck no because they were just like hey
what's that curious what okay what do
you think that is
no my point is if it isn't if it is
aligned you live to say another day if
it's not a lion and you walk away you
live another day right if you don't
think it's a lion and it is a lion
you're you're done for
you right so Nick there's some sense of
pattern recognition that I I think is
completely understandable for our
survival right
yeah absolutely and that pattern
recognition like you say is the kind of
thing that has kept us alive and the
people and the the our distant ancestors
that were good at spotting these
patterns they lived a little bit longer
they were able to have Offspring
propagate their genes and so forth but
the type of patterns that we need to
recognize into in today's society have
changed you know we we are we've evolved
with these heuristics these mental
shortcuts which give us vague
approximations of the truth but but
these but these vague approximations can
also be inaccurate it can lead to
inaccurate conclusions and they can be
high marketing companies can exactly
they can be hijacked exactly right so so
okay so the the modern version of being
able to identify a lion
and therefore altering our critical
faculties would be
improved personal science literacy that
only works Gary if for not having done
so you die and don't have any Offspring
well no I mean I don't I don't think
people are dying from dietary
supplements or a fad diet or or right so
I don't know that there's evolutionary
Force to change it Nick what do you
think well on a macro scale probably not
but it comes at its core we're talking
about Bertram Russell's point about how
intuition is really important that
intuition must be tempered by intellect
intuition versus intellect and now in in
the Modern Age we have the tools and the
Technologies and the intellect to be
able to determine the difference between
science and pseudoscience between
information and misinformation it's just
like like in the record show this is the
first time
in startalk's 13-year history that
Bertrand Russell was mentioned okay
and it's totally the case of Brookshire
and Russell a a
um a philosopher mathematician a
brilliant guy uh I have most of his
books and uh at turn of the century into
the 20th century so he's a good guy very
thoughtful very deep thinker and his
book on mysticism and logic I mean it's
an essay but he describes this battle
between intuition and intellect and the
point is we now have these skills we now
have the intellectual skills to be able
to apply the scientific method and
determine if things are real or fake and
we're not using it as well as we could
be using it of course yeah it doesn't
feel good yeah yeah yeah so where do you
see it doctor if we leave pseudoscience
unchecked where which Rabbit Hole does
it drag us down I mean how harmless is
it how harm how harmful or harmless is
it yeah
well as I said it's impossible to if an
athlete okay we bring it back to the
sports metaphor and if an athlete uses a
supplement or they use cupping therapy
okay we use Michael Phelps I always come
back to Michael Phelps and cupping
because it's shooting fish in a barrel
but uh Michael Phelps the most
successful athlete not just the most
successful swimmer but the most
successful Olympic athlete of all time
given all his medal all and he came out
of the Rio 2016 games with big circular
bruises all over his back I thought
those were hickeys oh my God yes he
wishes he probably had those as well
so and this is the result of an ancient
Chinese Therapy known as cupping and
it's it's widely considered to be a
pseudoscience there's no real you know
underpinning mechanism for it and it's
widely discredited by scientists and he
uses it to
mitigate muscle soreness as a lot of
Ethics a lot of swimmers now use it
surprisingly and this propagated into
the mainstream culture if you look at
the number of Wikipedia searches for
cupping therapy they reached an all-time
high at about a couple of hundred
thousand hits a day immediately after
the Rio 2016 games when Phelps appeared
on live TV at the swimming finals so he
uses it to treat muscle soreness but
there are some societies that say the
cupping therapy can be used to treat
asthma and asthmatic symptoms right
we're getting a little bit of thin ice
here when and I strongly I strongly
recommend that you don't use cupping
therapy to treat your asthmatic symptoms
so this is the real harm that can be
done and I'm sure you guys are familiar
with what's the harm.net which is
documented nearly 400 000 cases of
people who have sadly lost their lives
because they tried to use alternative
therapies to treat something that needed
a real intervention did not know about
that website what's theharm.net what's
the harm.net yeah they've done all the
heavy lifting and you can search by
different alternative therapies and so
this would be harm that the medicine
that that purported medicine did to you
or the harm that was not cured by the
medicine and then it left was left
unchecked leading to the death of the
patient it's actually both yeah so it's
it's specifically alternative medicine
which has a it does have a specific
definition uh which is it's it's not not
conforming to what we know as mainstream
science or mainstream medicine
and and athletes need to understand that
they have they already know they have
huge influence upon mainstream yeah and
they are pioneering population Trends in
the use of Cam unsurprisingly can being
complementary and alternative medicine
so things like
puncture Reiki whatever whatever it
happens to be so guys you got to take a
quick break but when we come back
Dr Nick tiller he's gonna give us the
top six myths in the health and fitness
industry you want to be there for that
all right on start talk sports edition
we'll be right back
we're back StarTalk sports edition we're
with Dr Nick tiller the UCLA Medical
Center who's an expert on how to be a
skeptic with regard to all the claims of
physiology and exercise and nutritional
supplements and that's a field that
desperately needs a dose of skepticism
and in particular for this segment
apparently Nick you've got a list of six
myths by the way I don't like using the
word myth in that context because a myth
is a story where you can learn from it
so let's just call it
yeah so I've got the list here let's
start with number one the fact that
people think that there's a simple
solution to complex problems and
challenges in our lives so what's up
with that Nick the health and wellness
industry health and fitness industry is
based on this idea that there are Simple
Solutions to complex problems so
whatever your health and wellness health
and fitness goal happens to be there is
a product a supplement a fat diet and
exercise program a garment that you can
buy that will expedite you to your
health and wellness goals because and
people love this idea for the reasons
that we spoke about in the last segment
you know that we've that we've evolved
for the quick fix we've evolved to take
these shortcuts people love the idea
that you can expedite these things that
otherwise would take a lot of time and
effort to accomplish
it's not just physiology I remember I I
even tweeted this once because it
reached that level where you you have
you dine at some one's house and the
food is amazing the food is amazing and
so you ask the the person who prepared
the meal what's your secret in this dish
well the secret is six years of culinary
study right and a master's degree in you
know World herbs or something that's the
secret they don't want to hear that they
want to know there's just one thing you
did that turned it something ordinary
into something amazing yeah so it seems
like it's your secret cumin it's cumin
put it on everything so I interrupted uh
Nick go on no I said it's a really
important point because I I often I talk
about this stuff on in particularly
health and wellness but health and
wellness is just the medium to discuss
these these broader implications of
critical thinking but anything
meaningful that you would like to attain
whether it's losing weight getting in
shape learning a new instrument learning
to speak a foreign language becoming an
amazing cook you know becoming an
astrophysicist these things take time
and effort to accomplish it's not going
to happen overnight but in health and
wellness we assume that there must be
some kind of quick fix but anything
meaningful takes time and effort to
accomplish are we just being lazy or are
we trying our best to be efficient and
is that how we've kind of evolved
through through the process lazy is
efficient that
seriously if you're sufficiently
efficient you have the luxury to be lazy
that's how I look right yeah okay but
also I mean if you look at the way we
evolved I mean we didn't evolve getting
up and going to you know get coffee and
we evolved Hunter Gathering you know
nomadic like we had to walk long
distances we set up camp every night you
had to gather your food in the morning
you had to go on long distances to kill
something and drag it back to the people
and so conservation of energy is very
important to us as a species I didn't
know you really wanted to narrate a
nature documentary
this is important this is the balance
between calorific expenditure and
calorific gain from whatever I didn't
know I was saying that
you just I didn't realize what did you
call it well okay so it's the balance
between the calories you expend going
hunting and Gathering and the calories
you gain to bring back to eat right how
many calories does it take you to to
obtain the calorie that you consumed and
if it's more than the if it's more than
you consume you go extinct Nick Wonder
studies done with chimpanzees where they
Place certain foodstuffs in certain
different locations and then the
chimpanzees worked out strategies to be
more efficient am I am I right very good
I had that in my mind I was just going
to mention that anyway seal one thank
you I love it yeah so they've done
studies where they they've got groups of
chimpanzees and they showed them they
packaged almonds up in in different
quantities and some were packaged a
little bit more efficiently than others
and then they buried them in different
parts of this open field they showed the
chimpanzees where they were and then
they just let them loose and and the
chimpanzees went and sort them out in
the order that would give them the
greatest payoffs so basically to save as
much energy as possible so this there's
a very clear evolutionary advantage to
saving energy to saving calories
particularly because we we were never
assured of our next meal particularly
during the winter you know when the
berries and the vegetation you know died
away you were never you were never sure
when you were going to get your next
bonus of calories so so that kind of
economy is is really we're hardwired for
that economy
okay before we go to the fiction number
two quickly which which area of health
and fitness is do you find that people
are most
uh seeking the quick fixed
probably nutrition particularly
supplementation people love the idea
that there is a pill I mean this is if
you boil it down to the simplest the
easiest way to expedite health and
wellness is a pill that you can take
that's going to give you six-pack abs
buying yes we want that pill
tell me the pill he's on the Amazon
website I was ready
well yeah the irony is that if you um
that if you had a pill that could reduce
your you know a single pill that could
reduce your body fat percentage and
could increase your glucose control and
your insulin sensitivity and could
reduce your risk for cardiovascular
disease reduce your risk of type 2
diabetes it could make you fitter and
and make it beautiful and more handsome
yes right exactly give you more energy
reduce your you know your improve your
mental health the inventor of that pill
would win a Nobel Prize the reality is
that exercise does all of those things
if you can just do regular exercise it
gives you all of those advantages but
doing exercise takes time and it takes
and you get sweaty well that takes us
too fiction number two of that I
everyone presumes that weight management
depends on your exercise level and but
that can't be true because we know this
ozempic this this
um diabetes medicine that rich people
are taking where the just curbs their
appetite and they're dropping a pound a
week so Nick tell me about uh weight
loss
this one is frustrating for me as an
exercise scientist and people still
think that I'm a PE teacher you know I
think despite that's for nothing wrong
with being a teacher but I'm not one but
they're constantly asking me for
training advice and this kind of thing
but this one's frustrating because
people are often very well intentioned
they want to lose weight and get in
shape and so they start exercising
regularly maybe they start going to the
gym but if you're previously sedentary
so you're pretty much sitting around all
day you've got a sedentary job and then
you start being Physically Active let's
say you go to the gym three times a week
most people would would agree that
that's a reasonable place to start that
shows reasonable commitment
but if we actually look at if we do some
basic math and having us estimate how
many calories people are burning when
they go to the gym by the time they've
warmed up they do a bit of cardio they
lift some weights they're checking their
phone in between their resistance
sessions if we're being generous they
might burn 500 calories in a given gym
session right and it's kind of depends
right yeah yeah exactly and you do it
three times a week 1500 calories you
reward Yourself by going out for a pizza
I want a milkshake I've worked hard too
right and there's this one phenomenon
called the compensation effect where
people think well I've been good I've
been to the gym I you know I've been
working out so I can have that extra
slice of pizza I can have that extra
dessert and then they do they undo all
of the good that they've been working
towards the whole week so the point is
we have to get our eating figured out if
you if people want to get in shape
particularly losing body mass body fat
just going out and exercising is not
enough it's good for your cardiovascular
health and for muscle strength but it 80
comes down to eating I really like what
you said with the uh if you had a pill
that could do all these things uh you
get a Nobel Prize or you could just
exercise and do it diligently and in a
way that works for you so if we are
basing this as a balanced process what
sort of exercise regime does a person
need to go through you know are we
looking you've got to burn 2 000
calories while you're in the gym is it 3
000 calories so as you can enjoy it a
meal that you actually will enjoy rather
than just sitting there looking at stuff
and thinking I hate this and I hate
myself for doing this
unless you're a professional athlete
which you of course you you know you
were Gary
um unless you're training for Ultra
endurance exercise the number of
calories that you burn during training
is we we always say you can't outrun a
bad diet so it doesn't matter how many
training sessions that you're doing I
like that you can't go to bed I'll run a
cheeseburger you cannot run a
cheeseburger oh my God it doesn't matter
how many times a week you train for most
normal people so what we have to do is
just eat well 95 of the time which you
know it can be done it doesn't mean you
can't ever eat your dessert doesn't mean
you can't ever eat your pizza but it
does but if you're going to Five Guys on
a Tuesday lunch time that's that's not
the way that's not the way to go and the
the local Five Guys for me as lines of
people out there every single lunch time
so we've got to try and eat well most of
the time so that we can enjoy it when we
don't and we've got to get our activity
levels up
so put some numbers on this how many
what's an average
um calorie needs of a human being
uh for for uh I mean the very
approximate very important would be for
a a male two and a half thousand
calories a day for a female about 2 000
calories okay so two thousand plus a day
and uh how many calories are in a
McDonald's Quarter Pounder or big meal
five five thousand five thousand
the meal I would guess two thousand but
I haven't looked it up but it's uh okay
so when the the cheeseburger the big
cheeseburger or the double cheeseburger
with the french fries and a soft drink
and and all that that's that's almost
all of the calorie needs that you have
in a day
right
okay well there you have it so there it
is on McDonald's days that's all you get
that's all you can
enjoy it right and to go one step
further people often will will train
really hard and they'll eat really well
and they'll have one day a week which is
they'll have a cheat Meal which I don't
like the terminology because it implies
that you're doing something wrong and I
don't like that at all but their cheat
meal will last six hours and they'll
consume about 8 000 calories
that's not the way to do it either it's
like yeah Thanksgiving dinner can't be a
cheap right right yeah exactly right all
right so I uh
section number three
that dietary supplements which are all
very highly priced are something that is
essential to your health so what's up
with that
I'm often asked what are the dietary
supplements that don't work you know
a short list and I always ask you know I
it should be reframing that what are the
supplements that work because there are
probably five or six that have a good
evidence base and the the other you know
tens of thousands really uh
don't work in the way that it's claimed
they're natural Nick right exactly is
always better right they're natural
anything anything that's natural it must
be better so right and the international
Journal of sports um the international
Society of Sports Nutrition published a
couple of years ago a pretty big review
article where they very articulately
stated the evidence for the supplements
that work and there were five of them
and there are something like twenty
thousand or more dietary supplements on
sale just in the United States so uh the
vast majority of them don't work and
even the ones that do work might provide
you with a small benefit maybe you know
up to three percent performance
enhancement but the rest of them really
don't don't work in the way that it's
claimed yeah what are they what those
that work what are they doing to you is
it just extra vitamins is it they've
thrown a dose of caffeine to pump you up
like what are they doing if they work at
all it varies so caffeine is one of the
supplements that works we know that it's
a that it's a potent stimulant it
increases your concentration your
attention your reaction time it also
works at the level of the muscle to
increase the strength of muscle
contraction so caffeine is one of them
creatine for example is another one that
can improve the the rate at which you
recover from a high intensity efforts
there's Decades of research showing that
that's very beneficial others you know
like um protein as a as an example if we
take protein we don't need protein
supplements but if we are struggling to
meet our protein demands because we have
a very active lifestyle then taking a
protein supplement to make sure that
you're breaking even can can be
beneficial to help you know with Muscle
Recovery or if you're an underinformed
vegetarian and doesn't otherwise know
where to get your protein right exactly
nothing wrong with being a vegetarian
but you've got to be a little bit more
considerate with where you're getting
your calories and how you're meeting
your protein requirements so so if
emotional work who's regulating the
market what who's who's looking over at
their shoulders that's the beauty of it
man nobody that's okay there's no FDA
requirement for supplements okay which
means we can make money so I say wait
wait no there's got to be like Nick so
the things you put we they are being
ingested so were they tested in some
other context and found to be safe and
therefore they just get all the safe
stuff put it together and make claims
for it so that the claims are not FDA
tested even if the substance is
yeah so you're both 50 right so the FDA
okay
the fbos are supposed to be doing a
better job of this but they're inundated
with claims and they can't keep up and
they're they're overly stringent with
some things and you know far too liberal
without this so that's part of the
problem the other thing is that the the
dietary Health Act of 2012 essentially
gave power back to the supplement
companies so as long as that they are
produced as long as they are producing
supplements that have already gone
through some kind of basic screening
process they don't need to get
pre-approval from the FDA so a
supplement can go on sale and as long as
it has within it a list of you know pre
pre-existing ingredients that are
pre-approved for whatever reason it
doesn't have to be any evidence of
efficacy and they will only take you off
the market if there is proven evidence
of safety problems if there's proven
evidence of harm so which is kind of
backwards right they should have to
prove that it's safe before they put it
on Market but we're all effectively the
guinea pigs they'll only take it off the
market if we can show that it's uh that
it's harmful if most of the supplements
are garbage
uh then we eat healthy but not everybody
is in a socio-economic situation where
they can constantly afford to bankroll a
fresh and healthy diet where are we
looking for our solution to that issue
Soylent Green
and let me let me reword Gary's question
and then
high calorie
tasty
salty fatty sugary snacks are highly are
widely available and inexpensive
and so at some level you can ask is
there some wealth threshold above which
a person can stay healthy against the
forces of the food industry that would
otherwise have you eat their junk food
and let's take a break and when we come
back Nick is going to answer that
question I think Nick are you okay I'll
do my best you'll do your best all right
uh stay with us we still have three more
of the top six fictions that people
think is actually going on with their
health and Physiology on StarTalk sports
edition we'll be right back
we're back StarTalk sports edition with
Dr Nick tiller one of the world's
leading authorities in the physiology
and pathophysiology of extreme exercise
which is great we didn't talk about that
yet but we will uh while also being an
ultra marathon runner himself
uh I got him on the show because he's
the author or we would do this anyway
but he happens to also be the author of
the skeptic's guide to Sports Science
and just he's an all-around critical
thinker which the world doesn't have
enough of so we left off with dietary
supplements so Nick I was just sort of
fleshing out
Gary's question regarding a person's uh
economic
standing where we are bombarded with
very tasty high fat high sugar processed
junk food fast food and it's so there
and it's so accessible and
you have to like you need higher income
to live in a place where people will
sell you healthy food is that have you
studied the economics of this
I haven't specifically studied the the
socioeconomics of this but if we look at
the the associations of socioeconomic
class with the rates of underlying
health problems or the racial obesity
there's there's always a very you know
close Association and you hit the nail
on the head there that junk food is very
cheap and you can buy a lot of it
relatively inexpensively whereas a nice
has high calorie density too it's like
calorie that's sort of by the by that
that sort of has the on at the
unintended or the uh unwanted side
effect of making people overweight but
the people buy it because it's cheap and
so people who are below the poverty line
are much more likely to buy the
inexpensive food that happens to be very
unhealthy then then pick out fresh
vegetables and fresh fruit and salads
and things that uh that that are going
to cost them a lot more money so you and
it's particularly you know I lived in
California for three years and it's it's
exceptionally expensive place to live
and uh particularly in Los Angeles and
you can go and buy your groceries weeks
a week and you can go and prepare your
meals for yourself but you'll bet you're
basically paying about the same amount
of money because groceries are so
expensive you'll pay about the same
amount of money to go and get a takeout
and so most people are going to prefer
to go to take out and the availability
the accessibility is is so much High
there as well okay so Gary did that
address because I fleshed out your
question but no no it did thank you let
me step on it yeah it's just the fact
the fact is Neil people are getting more
obese I think the numbers and the doctor
will back me up I think is how long
before we get to a one in two will be
clinically obese so if people like
teachers thank you so if people aren't
losing weight and all these weight loss
supplements and products are on the
market
who's losing weight
the only the only weight being lost is
out of a wallet or a or a purse and
that's that's just it so it's it's got
to be a trend that has to be addressed
really
if you look at the profits from the from
the diet and weight loss industry
that you know that's like 70 billion
dollars a year something like that and
those profits are now an all-time high
the race of obesity have been trending
upwards for the last couple of decades
since the 70s really and the rates of
obesity are also at an all-time high so
there's a disconnect here between the
amount of money that we're spending on
weight loss and and obesity rates in the
overall population so
it would be much worse without that
maybe that's how you should be thinking
about it well perhaps perhaps well you
say that but I guess part of the problem
is that people are investing in
strategies that don't work like fad
diets and supplements so particularly
with fat diets I think it's important to
touch on this very briefly
fiction number four is the idea that if
you don't use your muscles they turn
into fat or if you work out your fat
turns to muscles that's that seems
patently obvious that that's not true
but that seems to relate to where you're
going right now
yeah I think the two things are
connected because if if you if you
aren't exercising and instead you just
follow a fat diet you're going to lose
weight acutely and you're going to lose
weight very quickly because you're not
getting in very many calories but fat
diets don't teach people how to eat
healthily in a long-term sustainable way
right so so we see what's called yo-yo
dieting somebody will lose a bit of
weight they'll eventually fall off the
wagon they'll regain if you do one or
two year follow-up studies people regain
all of the weight that they've lost a
third of people regain more weight than
they originally lost oh oh and then and
then they'll go on to another fad diet
and we get this this weight cycling and
it's the it's the the yo-yoing effect
that causes the greatest risk to
cardiovascular health and the greatest
risk of psychopathology
so it's not it's not just you know
gaining weight and uh and trying to lose
weight but it's the yo-yoing that seems
to have the negative effect so it seems
like the uh the focus should be on a
healthy diet as a lifestyle yeah not not
getting to a certain weight or you know
any any other goal except the the the
the lifestyle itself should be the goal
right and but but if you say to somebody
if you say to somebody just just eat
well every day
I don't know that's a that's a big ask
if you say to somebody just follow this
diet for six weeks and you'll lose the
weight that's much more appealing it has
to be packaged now in this modern modern
society the intervention has to be
packaged and it has to be sold and it
has to be commercialized otherwise
people don't buy into it
that's that's the sort of paradox that
we're facing whereas really what we need
to be doing exactly as you say Chuck we
just need to be following good eating
habits on a day-to-day basis and being
being Physically Active that's the only
secret is there is no secret so what
about a fiction number five where the
people who are most successful on social
media must really know what they're
talking about if they're giving you
Fitness advice and what what intrigues
me most and I only came to this
realization recently like weeks ago
months ago it was if if you're channel
surfing on YouTube and you come across
someone that says
everyone else thinks this is true
but it's not I'm gonna give you the real
truth
right that that's that's you want to
listen to that person right everyone has
you do that but they're all wrong so
this tell us about what role social
media is playing in this
I'm sort of more and more of the opinion
the more I learned about how these
social media platforms work and the
algorithms generate content the more
convinced I am that uh they probably
cause more harm than good in modern
society it's a big mistake yeah okay
yeah I don't want to feel that way but I
do just the way you are yeah yeah and
it's not just in health and wellness
it's any any time that Society can be
harmed by misinformation and
disinformation which we see across the
Spectrum not just in health and wellness
but in you know politics Public Health
policy and so forth so so this is a big
problem and social media is pervasive
young people get most of their news and
entertain entertainment from social
media
it seems to me if I have a if I have a
weight loss gimmick fad whatever
and I have the most followers
and you can read the comment thread and
say this really works and and you look
at the statistics on that why wouldn't
those with the highest followers why
isn't that alone sort of a crowd-sourced
vote of confidence that it works
yeah that's a really good point actually
and the the type of people that are
giving this advice you've got I guess
it's important to look at the motives
that they have people with the most
followers tend to have a lot more
sponsorship for example so they might be
selling a particular supplement or a
product because they're being paid to do
so and a lot of the time uh you know on
Instagram for example you're supposed to
say you're supposed to tag something as
a sponsored post and a lot of the time
these posts these posts are sponsored
but they're not labeling it
appropriately so they can kind of bypass
the um the rules and regulations there
and a lot of the time these things are
working in the context sometimes they
may really work you know we can't
discount everything
it can't just be cynical but a lot of
the time these things are working in the
context of placebo and we're not able to
determine the things that are really
working the things that are working just
just in our minds so that's why the the
advice should always be judged on merits
and Merit alone
but aren't we I'm sorry no but aren't we
into a peer pressure situation I mean
our society now judges individuals on
their number of social media followers
so you can't be anybody unless you've
got an absolute gazillion billion load
and we've all and we've kind of slept
walked into this I mean an individual
cannot and surely must not be judged
alone on the number of media followers
and I always say that uh social media
followers are not credentials because
it's sort of an appeal to Authority
right
and that's why it's important to as I
said judge the advice on Merit and if we
bring it back to health and wellness or
Sport and exercise we look at the people
that have the most influence on social
media they're usually high profile
athletes and it's sad to say that
somebody like Cristiano Ronaldo who Gary
will be very familiar with but he's a
very famous Portuguese soccer player has
something like 400 million followers
across various platforms and the number
of uh products and supplements and
things that is constantly being
sponsored to promote I mean it's endless
and so if people just were investing in
in all of the products that this guy is
uh is getting paid to promote uh we do
nothing but follow pseudoscience so
we've got to be mindful that the people
that have the greatest influence are not
necessarily the ones giving the good
advice Nick you used a term I want to
make sure we're on the same page you
said appeal to Authority just tell
everybody what that means
so the the appeal to Authority uh
essentially is assuming that the advice
that's being given by somebody who is in
seemingly in some kind of authority
authoritative position that the advice
is necessarily better or correct or true
in and of itself because it's being
because it's being promoted by by this
individual this happens in the in the
UFO World a lot where they say this
person is a three-star General and
listen to his testimony about the UFO
then that would be an appeal to
Authority right right because if if
anyone's going to know if they've seen
an alien spacecraft it's going to be a
three-star generals
what was it what was it Carl Sagan's
quote what is that the extreme claims
require extreme evidence extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
yeah I mean if you sort of paraphrased
it from from LaPlace but yeah
essentially it's uh extraordinary claims
require extraordinary extraordinary
evidence and in health and wellness we
get extraordinary claims all the time
but the evidence is is far from
extraordinary it's very ordinary in fact
well let's go to our last myth again I
said I wouldn't use the word myth a last
bit of fiction and you you hinted at the
beginning but I want to tease it out a
little more and it was your critique of
Chiropractic and just just once you
summarize it and then I want to give a
mild rebuttal to it let me hear why a
skeptic looks at Chiropractic as are you
crazy okay so what's going on there
well a good scientist if it's a good
skeptic will always Point their nose in
the in the direction of the research
right in the direction of the evidence
and there are lots of commercial claims
for Chiropractic it's based on this idea
of spinal manipulation and subluxations
of the spine although some chiropractors
have tried to move away from that sort
of premise of treatment
it's used widely in professional sport
especially in the NFL something like 60
to 70 percent of NFL teams either have a
chiropractor on their payroll or
regularly refer athletes to
chiropractors
so how could they be wrong right why am
I going to listen to you your snot-nosed
academic you happen to write a little
book or the NFL and 60 of them why
should I listen to you at all you
elitist Egghead who hates right
Chiropractic so that so that's important
that's an important point and of course
when it comes to when it comes to
matters of evidence-based practice my
job is to partly to interpret evidence
so I you could say I'm an expert in
interpreting it in reading and
interpreting and summarizing evidence so
in there's nothing wrong with elitism in
certain circumstances when you know if
you need a surgery you want to go to an
elite surgeon I don't think I'm the
first person to say this if you're
getting on a plane you want an elite
pilot to take you know to take you from
A to B so when it comes to matters of
Public Health policy all of a sudden
Everyone's an expert and we don't have
enough time for the for the for the
elites and it's exactly the same um with
respect to health and wellness when it
comes to Chiropractic if you look at the
evidence we just mentioned LaPlace and
Sagan extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
if you look at the evidence and you
interpret it very clearly there is no
signal for Chiropractic really doing
anything and Chiropractic is in in it's
very pervasive in in mainstream culture
lots of physiotherapies try this you can
get a PhD or doctorate in Chiropractic
um but the evidence suggests that it
doesn't actually do anything okay so
here's my mild pushback you ready please
so they're very mild it's
um you know I've read the founding
documents of Chiropractic and it is what
the are you crazy you know the idea that
practically every ailment that your body
experiences can be cured by the
manipulation of your spine all right
just read some of the early documents
and it's like how did this ever become
an entire branch of medicine and so so
now I say
suppose the foundational ideas are all
wrong
but the manipulation of the spine
still has benefit even if the founding
principles are flawed and so take for
example I let's say we have I'm a I'm an
indigenous population and there's this
tree that is worshiped for generations
and you eat of the bark of the tree and
it it relieves ailments but only if you
pray to the tree and the gods all right
well what's going on here well there's
aspirin the active ingredient of aspirin
in the bark okay so as a scientist I can
I can be reductionist and say just
extract this whatever the the
ingredients and just take that and leave
out the praying and the tree and
everything else
but if you don't know that or you don't
care it still has this benefit even if
the whole framework of it is has no
foundation in what is objectively true
so can we say that the manipulation of
the spine
can have some benefit whether or not
it's a chiropractor doing it or somebody
who likes you know popping your muscles
you know or whatever cracking your back
you know in in a therapeutic way which I
used to do for my sister all the time
so that's my I'm just pushing back on
yeah throw out the premise but can there
that doesn't mean it still can't be
beneficial
I thought you were saying don't see a
chiropractor just have some aspirin
but interestingly you're not too far
away from the truth because if if
chiropractic works for anything at all
it might be in relieving some instances
of lower back pain but it's no more
effective than taking an aspirin taking
up taking a Tylenol or going for a walk
or having some bed rest right and but
maybe we just like people's hands
touching our bodies and there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that and
Homeopathy is very popular not because
the not because the drugs that they are
prescribing actually do anything but
because they get you know average of
eight minutes
um with your normal primary care
provider you get 20 minutes with a
homeopath and with a homeopathic doctor
so if you're actually getting more time
you're actually getting the one one to
one and um interesting pastoral care
that you're actually benefiting from
which is the role nurses have played
forever right yeah right here that you
get and that's not to make sense it
makes sense it's like going for massage
therapy like when you go from massage
therapy a lot of it is the experience it
isn't just the massage right it's the
it's the soothing music that they're
playing the little Fountain that's in
the corner
of water right the little bonsai tree
that you're looking at as as you're
getting rubbed down you know and you
know and you walk away and you're like
oh my God that was so good it's so
therapeutic but the truth is if you
walked into the same room the lights
were super bright right in hospital
lights yeah hospitalized they have metal
music playing and they had a guy with a
cigar in his mouth like hey how you just
doing come on lay down here let me get
the word
you wouldn't come out of that experience
feeling the same way even though the
muscles were received the same thing in
the same way right all right he's done
some experiments there the real question
is if you had some kind of if you had a
broken leg or you had some kind of uh
you know a real medical problem trauma
injury especially yeah a real you know
some kind of traumatic injury would you
prefer to go to to the to the massage
therapist is going to give you a nice
relaxing treatment but isn't really
going to be able to help you with your
broken leg or would you prefer I mean
it's a bit of a false dichotomy but
would you or would you prefer to go up
to the heavy metal music bright light
clinical room with the guys smoking the
cigar who's actually going to be able to
fix your leg and help your problem right
yeah I mean yeah without a doubt it's I
I see what you're saying it really comes
down to uh evidence-based results is
kind of everything that you're dealing
with what are what is the evidence-based
result of of what is measurable and what
we can you know confirm and yeah well
and also these things are not are not
annoying either you know all Medical
Treatments come with risks right and
musicians will balance the the benefits
of the thing with the risks of the thing
and then they'll make a risk to benefit
analysis there are people who've been
harmed by chiropractors that have have
bunched many yeah and when the when the
benefits hinge on Placebo the risks
can't be justified and then you see
neonate Chiropractic where they're
manipulating the spines of babies and
you know yeah and you want baby got its
neck broken not too long ago
I blame the parents I'm sorry I don't
blame the chiropractor I blame the
parents nobody should be taking their
baby to a car what baby is so stressed
out or is is lifting it's lifting things
so heavy that it needs a chiropractic
yes they know they barely have bones yet
they're all cartilage still I've never
seen a baby that was inflexible
well the babies I got lower back pain
my back is killing me but my rheumatism
it's crazy
you've only got to see one of these
videos pop up on your social social
media feed and then you realize this
this thing's this thing's nuts this this
shouldn't be allowed to go ahead and I
just have to scroll past that I can't
watch those things well Nick this has
been a delight I mean an upsetting
Delight but
yeah
no no give us give me give me a fast
positive thought to finish on here
what's what is the is the future bright
well let's put it this way we're all in
control of our own destiny to a certain
extent and whatever your health and
wellness goals
uh it's it's a sad truth you have to
accept it like it's going to take time
and it's going to take some effort as
soon as you digest that fact and get
that into your head regardless of what
it is in health awareness or outside of
Health and Wellness you can achieve
those things at the corner a little bit
cliche just takes time and effort just
put in the time and effort and you can
do it you can achieve it and if we
talked maybe put it out there if we
taught
um healthy scientific skepticism as a
branch of learning in school then we
would nip this in the bud and it would
never reach the state to begin with is
that look at that absolutely and and
doing skepticism and critical thinking
is doing the heavy lifting right yes yes
yeah same thing oh all right guys there
we're screwed
there you go guys
Nick has been great to have you how do
we find you on social media
uh so you can find me primarily I I'm on
Twitter at NB tiller and you can find
out more about my work on my website
nietiller.com n b letter N enter letter
B tiller
okay we'll we'll look for you I uh
thanks for being on the show and your
and your book uh tell me the title again
the full title the Skeptics Guide the
sports science confronting myths of the
health and fitness industry yeah there
it is
it's a great title Gary always good to
have you there a pleasure friend all
right be good all y'all Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
foreign
[Music]